[Music]
you know one of the hallmarks of any
dictatorial regime is pettiness this is
certainly one thing that comes through
in soldier neeson's account of stalin's
russia or any account of nearly any
autocrat throughout history they are
ruthless and
megalomaniacal tyrants with broad and
usually horrifying aspirations but they
also focus just as much if not more on
the slight and trivial after all
uh you know that you you really have
control over a populace if they will
obey you even when it comes to the most
trifling of matters
if they will not only submit to and go
along with your grandest ambitions but
also conform themselves to your demands
in every minor and seemingly
insignificant way
then you have total control the people
are your marionettes and you are their
puppet masters they've ceded everything
to you given up nearly all of their
personal agency this is the goal
ultimately and it's depressing to see
how often this goal has been realized
in different countries and civilizations
at different times in history and we're
seeing this principle at work of course
across the world right now as we
discussed in the name of stopping the
spread of covet and we've talked plenty
about that and we'll continue to discuss
it but right now
i want to focus on something else
because this is also the point behind
what we call cancel culture we've come
to think of cancel culture as its own
thing right a separate phenomenon
but really it's all a part of the left's
overall plan to control and dominate
society
we might think of cancer culture as the
specific mechanism by which the left
imposes itself in those especially petty
and seemingly trivial ways
that is exactly why cancel culture is
such an important issue and such a
threat the pettiness is the point the
pettiness is power
and speaking of petty it doesn't get
more petty than this
as i briefly discussed on the show on
friday the cancel culture mob has taken
a special interest in the hunt for a new
host of jeopardy
why do they care so much about this
um why does the search for a game show
host matter
well because it doesn't matter
it matters because it doesn't
it's important because it isn't
in this case after weeks of auditioning
potential hosts the decision was made to
bring a guy named mike richards on board
as host now mike richards also happens
to be the executive producer of jeopardy
given that the executive brewers of
jeopardy is one of the guys primarily
responsible for finding a host of
jeopardy it would seem that he kind of
went through this whole talent search
only to say uh never mind i'll actually
do it myself
it may even seem like the talent search
was a ruse
kind of a symbolic gesture at most and
maybe it was but who cares they can hire
whoever they want to be host of jeopardy
the decision has no effect large or
small on anyone else's life
well maybe i should speak only for
myself and say that i have never in my
life experienced any form
of deprivation or suffering that could
be traced back to a network tv game show
i can't imagine how anyone could have a
different experience in that regard
say what you want about pat sajak for
example and i like him personally but
even if you don't i can't imagine anyone
in a moment of anguish and despair
crying out damn you pat sajak this is
all your fault
nevertheless
the canceled mob has decided that the
game show host issue is now of urgent
national importance and that's why once
mike richards was anointed the new host
or anointed himself i should say the
news
they immediately set out to destroy him
as if he was a front-runner for the
presidential nomination the mob went
digging for dirt looking for any
skeletons they might find
the reason for their opposition to
richards it's pretty obvious as
described in many articles including
this one from the ap it says quote
giving the flagship show to richards
who's firmly in the cookie-cutter host
of a
the cookie-cutter host mold of a white
square-jawed young man
struck some as proof of an insincere
effort by the studio to consider a woman
a person of color or someone from the
lgbtq community more than half of the
guest hosts fall into one or more of
those groups
so mike richards had committed the sin
of being white and male that's really
the problem of course alex trebek was
also white and male and everybody loved
him
even the left loved him
but i think trebek was kind of
grandfathered in
he was a beloved figure who became
beloved before it was decided that all
white men are evil bastards
the left kind of allowed him to retain
his beloved status
a magnanimous exception fueled by their
own nostalgia but no such exception
would be granted to poor mike richards
so it didn't take long before they found
what they were looking for apparently
richards had made a few offensive jokes
on a podcast about eight or nine years
ago
um again does it matter that the host of
jeopardy made crew jokes about almost a
decade ago
on a podcast that nobody listened to
is there any reason why this should
preclude him from holding note cards and
asking trivia questions
no but once again the pettiness is the
point
richards not one to break from the mold
immediately issue the standard groveling
apology in a statement he said quote it
is humbling to confront a terribly
embarrassing moment of misjudgment
thoughtlessness and insensitivity from
nearly a decade ago looking back now
there's no excuse of course for the
comments i made on the podcast and i am
deeply sorry the podcast was intended to
be a series of irreverent conversations
between long-time friends who had a
history of joking around even with the
passage of time it's more than clear
that my attempts to be funny and
provocative were not acceptable and i
have removed the episodes my
responsibilities today as a father
husband and a public personality who
speaks to many people through my role on
television means that i have substantial
and serious obligations as a role model
and i intend to live up to them
that was a statement now of course what
he should have said was something like
it's come to my attention that many of
you are pretending to be offended by
comments i made on a podcast that nobody
listened to or cared about until five
seconds ago but i also realized that
most of the offended people are too
stupid to even watch jeopardy in the
first place so what do i care go watch a
sub 95 iq game show like wheel of
fortune instead you dummies
now if richards had issued a statement
like that
i actually would vote for him for
president
but we've yet to find almost anyone with
the guts to stand up to the cancel mob
in such an aggressive way or really in
any way at all
and uh richard certainly wasn't going to
be the first he apologized
they didn't accept it
and then he was forced to step down from
the role the same song on repeat over
and over and over again
and it doesn't stop there because it
never does
you see the producers of jeopardy
had already tried to preempt the
inevitable outrage over choosing a white
male
by actually appointing two hosts of
jeopardy they selected a woman actress
mayam bialik who was on big bang theory
and some other stuff i don't know
to host the prime time jeopardy specials
that they plan on doing periodically
so really they they invented
these specials that they're going to
start doing
just so that they could appoint a female
host and then not be accused of
prioritizing you know males over females
they were trying to be equitable and
equal and all that kind of stuff
and that didn't work either the problem
is that biolic is uh not a person of
color and is not trans and is not even
gay or lesbian or gender non-conforming
as far as anyone knows and you know what
that means here's new newsweek with the
latest article
they say quote mike richards stepped
down friday from his recently announced
appointment as jeopardy hosts due to
controversial comments he made years ago
now some people on social media are
calling on mayam bialik who was hired to
host the primetime version of the show
and specials to do the same
yes she has to go too
why well they went looking for reasons
and they discovered that about nine
years ago
she said that she didn't want to get her
kids vaccinated
okay that's how much they're scraping
the barrel right now to find a reason
that's it
she expressed some measure of vaccine
hesitancy nearly a decade before covet
19 existed
and that's their pretense for calling
for her ouster
but the real reason is that she is by
the canceled mob's estimation
too straight and two white
the mob has decided that the true host
of jeopardy the man who is destined for
the position as as if it is written in
the stars is levar burton known to my
generation as the man from reading
rainbow the problem is that levar burton
tried out for the gig and was pretty
terrible
but this is no problem at all to the
cancel mob
doesn't matter if he's good at it or not
or if he deserves the job on the merits
all that matters is that he's black
and having a black host of jeopardy
is the one piece missing
the one box left to check
the one thing that will finally heal our
national wounds and bring about an era
of peace and prosperity
or maybe not but it doesn't matter
the point is to impose themselves and to
bully jeopardy into selecting a host
that they prefer simply for the sake of
it
because they can
because that's what petty tyrants do
everything matters to the petty tyrants
especially the things that don't matter
at all
and that's why the cancel mob has made
jeopardy into a central battlefield and
it's also why they today paradoxically
are the ones who are
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated